will you marry me so where are you
getting married
Oh June wedding Cabo Santa Morris Resort
we'd be happy to help you would love to
host engagement party at the lodge oh no
that's really sweet of you but you don't
have to worry about that we'll do the
engagement party here that is what you
want right an engagement party in the
snow for a summer themed wedding
tell me how that makes any sense Howie
is this what you want or is it what
Lucas wants it's what we want
picabo's Santa Morris just called the
President of Mexico wants to throw his
daughters continue outta there on the
same weekend town can I even do this if
he already paid for it it's too bad that
we didn't know all this beforehand we
could have just gotten married here
that's not such a bad idea actually
oh we have some news we want to have the
wedding here this weekend
we just love that wouldn't we where are
you going to have the ceremony we would
have it in the barn you find a lot of
good parties there Oh waiting in a bar
you have to stop interfering with my
life especially when it comes to mind
and Lucas's marriage
it's getting married in Cabo really ever
what you wanted it's been my dream
wedding since I was a little girl
[Music]
honey after watching you and Lucas
dancing last night I now realized that
nothing there could compare to what was
happening in that moment here you are my
dream wedding Lucas anyplace anytime as
long as to you
[Music]
you